-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden
and Chinese President Xi Jinping
are reportedly
prepared to announce
the return of
the direct military hotline,
and -- this is fun -- they're
letting Biden pick the phone.
[ Laughter ]
The third Republican
presidential debate
was held last night in Miami.
What's the point?
It's like going to a NSYNC
concert without Justin.
We don't know the rest of you.
[ Laughter ]
During the first few minutes
of last night's debate,
moderator Lester Holt
admonished the crowd
several times
for cheering and applauding,
saying, "Let's not do this."
Man, you know, our political
decorum is in bad shape
when the moderator has to talk
to the audience
like they're his ex-wife.
[ Laughter ]
"Can we not do this today,
Bethany?
I'm just here
to drop off the kids."
During last night's debate,
Vivek Ramaswamy criticized
Nikki Haley's
foreign policy views
and said she was "Dick Cheney
in three-inch heels."
"Hey, I'm right here,"
said Ron DeSantis.
[ Laughter ]
After Vivek Ramaswamy criticized
Nikki Haley's daughter
for using TikTok
during last night's debate,
Haley told Ramaswamy to
"keep my daughter's name
out of your voice."
And even though he was
thousands of miles away,
Chris Rock instinctively ducked.
[ Laughter ]
During last night's debate,
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
said that voters
shouldn't support
former President Trump in 2024,
and added that he's a "different
guy than he was in 2016."
Of course, thanks to Trump
we're all different guys
than we were in 2016.
[ Laughter ]
Politico published an article
today after last night's debate
titled "Tim Scott's Girlfriend
Is, in Fact, Real."
However, jury's still out
on Tim Scott.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the quality of the
in-flight food onboard
Air Force Two has improved.
Oh, you mean
since Mike Pence used it?
The guy who thinks
oregano is a sin?
He threw away the beverage cart
when that Sprite
gave him a hangover.
The FBI and Italian authorities
announced yesterday
they arrested 17 men
allegedly connected
with the Gambino crime family
on charges including Mafia
association and arson.
Though, officials say
it could still be weeks
before Netflix is able to
release a show about it.
[ Laughter ]
A bear in Florida recently stole
a $45 Taco Bell order
from the front porch of a home.
Wait a minute.
How...
do you spend $45 at Taco Bell?
What did you order? All of it?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the FDA
has launched an investigation
into counterfeit versions
of the weight-loss drug Ozempic.
Users first became suspicious
when they noticed Wilma.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody!
We're off.
We've got a great show
for you tonight.